Hananoi It's a ritual that means that if you're at Hop, you're going to leave
the gods.  It also has the meaning of letting people know that a bear has been caught in the morning. What
is called a stance is
something humans cannot do.
Kamui lives there, and
I wonder if he's sitting on a mountain.
Weather and epidemics are beyond the reach of humans, so he's
Kamui.  It's been thought that humans don't take the
arrows, but they come from the front to hit the bows and arrows.In
exchange for being invited by humans and given grilled meat, we
want a box with sake that only humans can make.We can do it.
Repeatedly politely to
Mugi, I have to tell him that the human world is a good
place.If you treat him badly, he won't come down.
Move to the many altars
Walking with wooden shavings It's a gift
from humans to kamuy.
It's said to be a treasure. Even in that
world, gold has value, so if you have a lot of it, you'll be happy
[music]